Carrie starts off this hour in Georgia
hi Carrie how are you better than I
deserve what's up your phone is muffled
can you speak directly into it please
yes can you hear me better now yes ma'am
thank you okay and I have been engaged
since June
however we recently got married you know
justice of the peace and earning today
she could get and my insurance plan and
I have been on my debt free journey by
myself
what about 18 months and I am set to be
debt-free by March of next year
and he and I still don't live together
and we're not planning on moving in
until after the new year my question is
do we answer your phone is breaking up
on it you're going to speak directly in
on mine and focus on his after the fact
ah you're married now so there's no mind
in his it's ours okay and so we combine
everything we combined incomes we
combined assets we combined liabilities
and we plan a life together of how we
are gonna win and so you reset your debt
snowballs where he had a debt snowball
you had one now you integrate them and
you have one you reset your maybe steps
and you might have been on a different
baby step from him and you have one and
you reset your budget where we have one
and we're working together and we're
communicating why are you not moving in
with your husband until January not have
a break in insurance
I heard that what anger is move in and
she's out the years he's a volunteer
fireman because he's made commitment to
that fire department was gonna stay
there until the end of the year and
within an hour and a half away he let
mr. Silva's could not so we had not
planned on hunting a violent home
probably okay all right well I mean
however you guys want to do it but the
thing would be you combine your finances
as soon as possible you can whether you
move in together or whatever but legally
they're now combined under the law and
so you know you might as well start
working together and it's as if he's on
deployment or something with the
military for a few more months before he
gets to before you get to actually
combine your households physically but
yeah I would definitely combine
everything as soon as possible again you
can do it now or you can wait you
combine households physically I don't
care but the all the data that we have
shows that couples that work together
towards a common goal of the ones that
win with money couples that try to live
separate lives under one roof and call
that a marriage do not have a high
success rate with money or marriage for
that matter